who doesn't love efficiency I do
efficiency means more for less more
miles per gallon more light per what
more words per minute more for less is
the next best thing to something for
nothing
algorithms big data the cloud are giving
us more for less are we heading toward a
friction for utopia or toward a
nightmare of surveillance I don't know
my interest is in the present and I'd
like to show you how the past can help
us understand the present there's
nothing that summarizes both the promise
and the danger of efficiency like the
humble potato the potato originated in
the Andes and it's spread to Europe from
the ancient Inca the potato is a
masterpiece of balanced nutrition and it
had some very powerful friends King
Frederick the Great of Prussia was the
first enthusiast
he believed that the potato could help
increase the population of healthy
Prussians and the more healthy Prussians
the more healthy partion soldiers and
some of those healthy Prussian soldiers
captured a French military pharmacist
named Parmentier Parmentier at first was
appalled by the morning noon and night
diet fed to POWs of potatoes but he came
to enjoy it he thought they were making
him a healthier person and so when he
was released he took it on himself to
spread the potato to France and he had
some powerful friends Benjamin Franklin
advised him to hold a banquet at which
every dish included potatoes and
Franklin was the guest of honor even the
king and queen of France were
but were persuaded to wear potatoes the
a potato flowers pardon me the king the
King wore potato flour in his lapel and
the Queen wore a potato flower in her
hair that was a truly great public
relations idea but there was a catch the
potato was too efficient for Europe's
good in Ireland that seemed the miracle
potatoes flourished the population grew
but there was a hidden risk Ireland's
potatoes were genetically identical they
were a very efficient breed called the
lumper and the problem what the lumper
was that a blight from South America
that affected one potato would affect
them all British exploitation and
callousness played a role but it was
because of this monoculture that a
million people died and another two
million were forced to emigrate a plant
that was supposed to end famine created
one of the most tragic ones the problems
of efficiency today are less drastic but
more chronic they can also prolong the
evils that they were intended to solve
take the electronic medical record it
seems to be the answer to the problem of
doctors handwriting and it had the
benefit of providing much better data
for treatments in practice instead it
has meant much more electronic paperwork
and physicians are now complaining that
they have less rather than more time to
see patients individually the obsession
with efficiency can actually make us
less efficient efficiency also bites
back with false positives hospitals have
hundreds of devices registering alarms
too often their crying wolf it takes
time to rule those out and that time
results in fatigue stress and once more
the neglect of the problems of real
patients there are also false positives
in pattern recognition a school bus dude
from the wrong angle can resemble a
punching bag
so precious time is required to
eliminate misidentification false
negatives are a problem two algorithms
can learn a lot fast but they can tell
us only about the past so many future
classics get bad reviews like Moby Dick
or are turned down by multiple
publishers like the Harry Potter series
it can be wasteful to try to avoid all
waste efficiency is also a trap when the
opposition copies it take the late 19th
century French 75 millimeter artillery
piece it was a masterpiece of lethal
design this piece could fire a shell
every four seconds but that wasn't so
unusual but what was really brilliant
was that because of the recoil mechanism
it could return to the exact same
position without having to be reamed so
the effective rate of firing was
drastically increased now this seemed to
be a way for France to defeat Germany
the next time they fought but
predictably the Germans were working on
something very similar so when the first
world war broke out the result was the
trench warfare that lasted longer than
anybody had expected a technology that
was designed to shorten war prolonged it
the biggest cost of all maybe miss
opportunities the platform economy
connecting buyers and sellers can be a
great investment and we have seen that
in the last few weeks companies that are
still losing hundreds of millions of
dollars maybe creating billionaires with
initial public offerings but the really
difficult inventions are the physical
and chemical ones they mean bigger risks
they may be losing out because hardware
is hard it's much harder to scale up a
physical or chemical invention than it
is a software based invention think of
batteries lithium-ion batteries in
portable devices and electric cars are
based on a thirty-year-old principle how
many smartphone battery
today will last a full day on a single
charge
yes hardware is hard it took over 20
years for the patents on the principle
of dry photocopying by Chester Carlson
in 1938 to result in the Xerox 914
copier introduced in 1959 the small
brave company Haloid in Rochester New
York had to go through what most
corporations would never have tolerated
there was one failure after another and
one of the special problems was fire in
fact when the 914 was finally released
it still had a device that it was called
a scorch Eliminator but actually it was
a small fire extinguisher built in my
answer to all these questions is
inspired inefficiency data and
measurement are essential but they are
not enough let's leave room for human
intuition and human skills there are
seven facets of inspired inefficiency
first take the scenic route
say yes to serendipity wrong turns can
be productive once when I was exploring
the east bank of the Mississippi I took
the wrong turn I was approaching a toll
bridge crossing the Great River and the
toll collector said I could not turn
back so I paid my fifty cents that's all
it was at the time and I was in
Muscatine Iowa I had barely heard of
Muscatine but it proved to be a
fascinating place Muscatine had some of
the world's richest muscle beds a
century ago a third of the world's
buttons were produced in Muscatine 1.5
billion a year the less plants have
closed now but there is still a Museum
of the pearl button industry that's one
of the most unusual in the world but
buttons were only the beginning this is
the house in Muscatine where China's
future president stayed in 1986 as a
member of an agricultural delegation it
is now the sino us friendship
house and it's a pilgrimage site for
Chinese tourists how could I have
foreseen that second get up from the
couch sometimes it can be more efficient
to do things the hard way
consider the Internet of Things it's
wonderful to be able to control lights
set the thermostat even vacuum the room
without leaving one seat but medical
research has shown that actually
fidgeting getting up walking around is
one of the best things you can do for
your heart it's good for the heart and
the waistline third monetize your
mistakes great forms can be created by
imaginative development of accidents tad
Leske and architect of the Metropolitan
Opera at Lincoln Center was working on a
sketch and some white ink fell on the
drawing other people might just have
thrown it away but Leske was inspired to
produce a starburst chandelier that was
probably the most notable of its kind of
the 20th century forth sometimes try the
hard way it can be more efficient to be
less fluent psychologists call this
desirable difficulty taking detailed
notes with the keyboard would seem to be
the best way to grasp what a lecturer is
saying to be able to review it verbatim
however studies have shown that when we
have to abbreviate when we have to
summarize what a speaker is saying when
we're taking notes with a pen or a
pencil on paper we are processing that
information we're making that our own
and we are learning much more actively
than when we had just when we were just
transcribing what was being said
v get security through diversity
monoculture can be deadly
remember the potato it was efficient
until it wasn't
diversity applies to organizations too
software can tell what has made people
in an organization succeed in the past
and it's useful sometimes in screening
employees but remember the environment
is constantly changing
and software screening software has no
way to tell and we have no way to tell
who is going to be useful in the future
so we need to supplement whatever the
algorithm tells us by an intuition and
by looking for people with various
backgrounds and various outlooks six
achieve safety through redundancy in
human skills why did to 737 max aircraft
crash we still don't know the full story
but we know how to prevent future
tragedies we need multiple independent
systems if one fails then the others can
override it we also need skilled
operators to come to the rescue
and that means constant training vii be
rationally extravagant Thomas Edison was
the pioneer of the film industry as well
as of camera technology nobody has done
more for efficiency than Thomas Edison
but his core spreading broke down his
manager hired a so called
efficiency engineer who advised him to
save money by using more of the film
stock that he shot having fewer retakes
well Edison was a genius but he didn't
understand the new rules of feature
films and the fact that failure was
becoming the price of success on the
other hand some great directors like
Erich von Stroheim were the opposite
they were superb dramatists and Stroheim
was also a memorable actor but they
couldn't live within their budgets so
that was not sustainable
it was Irving Thalberg a former
secretary with intuitive genius who in
chief rational extravagance first at
Universal and then at MGM becoming the
ideal of the Hollywood producer summing
up to be truly efficient we need optimal
inefficiency the shortest path may be a
curve rather than a straight line
Charles Darwin understood that when he
encountered a tough problem he made a
circuit of a trail the sand walk that he
built behind his house a productive path
can be physical like Darwin's
or a virtual one or a knife or singing
detour from a path we had laid out too
much efficiency can weaken itself but a
bit of inspired inefficiency can
strengthen it sometimes the best way to
move forward is to follow a circle thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]